BUT FIRST, BILL CLINTON AND A
PARTY IN DENIAL.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
20 YEARS LATER, BILL CLINTON AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY REFUSED TO
LEARN THE LESSONS OF THE PAST.
EVEN WHEN CONFRONTED WITH
REALITY, THEY HAVE A PROBLEM
PROCESSING THE TRUTH.
DURING AN INTERVIEW TO PUSH HIS
NEW THRILLER THAT HE COWROTE
WITH JAMES PATTERSON COME UP
WARMER PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
WAS ASKED THIS BY NBC ANCHOR
CRAIG NELKIN.
>> IN 2018, WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT, HOW WOULD YOU
HAVE APPROACHED THE ACCUSATIONS
DIFFERENTLY?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE AN
ISSUE BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
THE FACTS INSTEAD OF THE
IMAGINED EFFECTS.
IF THE FACTS WHERE THE SAME
TODAY, I WOULDN'T.
A LOT OF THE FACTS HAVE BEEN
CONVENIENTLY OMITTED TO MAKE THE
STORY WORK.
>> Laura: WHICH FACTS ARE
THOSE?
MAYBE THIS FACT?
>> I DID NOT HAVE SEXUAL
RELATIONS WITH THAT WOMAN.
>> Laura: THIS CAME TO LIGHT
IN A SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASE
BROUGHT TO LIGHT BY PAULA JONES.
>> THAT'S AN UTTERLY FALSE
STATEMENT.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE MEANING OF
THE WORD "IS" IS.
>> Laura: "IS" IS IT STILL
RIDICULOUS THAT HE SAID IT?
YES, IT IS.
EVERY TIME I HEAR THAT, I STILL
CAN'T BELIEVE HE SAID THAT.
THE PRESIDENT EVENTUALLY
ADMITTED TO THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH LINSKY AND CALLED IT WRONG
AND A RECENT VANITY
VANITY
-- CONSTITUTED A GROSS ABUSE OF
POWER FOR THE MOST POWERFUL MAN
ON THE PLANET.
27 YEARS MY SENIOR WITH ENOUGH
LIFE EXPERIENCE TO KNOW BETTER.
HE WAS, AT THE TIME, IN THE
PINNACLE OF HIS CAREER, WHILE I
WAS IN MY FIRST JOB OUT OF
COLLEGE.
WHEN CLINTON WAS CONFRONTED WITH
ALL OF THIS, HE GOT VERY, VERY
DEFENSIVE.
>> ASKED IF YOU EVER APOLOGIZE,
SAID HE HAD.
>> I APPLIES TO EVERYBODY IN THE
WORLD.
>> YOU DID NOT APOLOGIZE TO HER.
>> I DID NOT TALK TO HER.
I -- I DO NOT -- I NEVER TALKED
TO HER.
I DO SAY PUBLICLY ON MORE THAN
ONE OCCASION, WE ALWAYS SEE IT.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT.
>> Laura: CONTINUED TO PRESS
THE PRESIDENT ABOUT A PRIVATE
APOLOGY CAUSING HIS COAUTHOR
JAMES PATTERSON TO RUSH IN LIKE
ALEX CROSS.
>> THIS THING, IT'S 20 YEARS
AGO.
COME ON.
TALK ABOUT JFK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT LBJ.
STOP ALREADY.
>> Laura: STOP ALREADY?
IS THAT THE NAME OF ONE OF HIS
NEW BOOKS?
IS SOME OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
CRIMES TAKE PLACE 20 YEARS AGO,
DID THEY NOT?
TO BE FORGIVE AND FORGET ALL
THOSE EGREGIOUS ASSAULTS AGAINST
WOMEN AS WELL?
BILL CLINTON RED-FACED AND
INDIGNANT REFUSED TO GIVE AN
INCH.
>> DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT KENNEDY -- DO YOU
BELIEVE PRESIDENT JOHNSON
SHOULD'VE RESIGNED?
I PROMISED TO DO A GOOD JOB
SINCE THEN WITH MY LIFE AND MY
WORK.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> Laura: I LIKE HOW HE TRIED
TO TURN THE TABLES ON THE
REPORTER.
BILL, HE'S THE REPORTER.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION TO RECONCILE WITH HIS
PUBLIC PATH.
YOU DO.
EVEN CLINTON'S OWN PARTY AT THIS
POINT, HE JUST WANTS HIM TO GO
AWAY.
THIS IS THE RUINED PATH OF THE
PARTY CONFRONTING ITS PATHETIC
RESIDENT.
BECAUSE, LIKE CLINTON, THE
DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO LEARN THE
LESSONS OF THE PAST.
DESPITE THE PREVIOUS EMBRACE OF
SEXUAL CREDITORS FROM WEINSTEIN
TO SPACEY, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ARRESTED A #MeToo MOVEMENT AND
POLITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THEY
HOPE WILL DELIVER FEMALE VOTERS
TO THE POLLS IN NOVEMBER.
BUT BILL CLINTON REMAINS A
BOTHERSOME OBSTACLE, IF THEY ARE
ASSUMING THE MORAL HIGH GROUND
ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
FOUND 80% OF DEMOCRAT VOTERS
CONSIDER SEXUAL HARASSMENT A TOP
ISSUE FOR THEM.
BUT ONLY 38% OF REPUBLICANS FEEL
THE SAME WAY.
THE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THEIR NEW WEDGE ISSUE.
OBAMA AND HILLARY CLINTON, COME
ON, LET'S REMEMBER, THEY WERE
ALL ABOUT DIVIDING AMERICANS
USING RACE, GENDER, TO DRIVE
PEOPLE TO THE POLLS.
AMAZINGLY, DEMOCRATS HAVE
EMBRACED THAT APPROACH TODAY.
AND WHILE OBAMA DISPARAGE
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS AS
BITTER PEOPLE CLING TO THEIR
GUNS AND RELIGION,
HILLARY CLINTON DARED INSANITY
FOR DARING TO VOTE FOR TRUMP.
BEYOND THE IMPEACHMENT AND
SHAMEFUL BEHAVIOR, BILL CLINTON
COULD ACTUALLY TEACH THE
DEMOCRATS A LOT.
OF COURSE, HE WAS A COMMITTED
GLOBALIST ON ISSUES LIKE CHINA
GETTING INTO THE WTO AND NAFTA,
HE WAS ALSO A SOUTHERN DEMOCRAT,
AND HE DID UNDERSTAND THAT
BLUE-COLLAR SENSIBILITY.
THE WORKING PEOPLE.
AND REMEMBER WHEN CLINTON
DECLARED THIS IN HIS REELECTION
YEAR STATE OF THE UNION?
>> WE KNOW AND WE HAVE WORK TO
GIVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE A
SMALLER, LESS BUREAUCRATIC
GOVERNMENT IN WASHINGTON.
AND WE HAVE TO GIVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ONES THAT LIVE WITHIN ITS
MEANS.
THE ERA OF BIG GOVERNMENT IS
OVER.
>> Laura: CLINTON OVERSAW
WELFARE REFORM, COLLABORATED
WITH REPUBLICANS TO PASS A
BALANCED BUDGET, AND HE SIGNED
THAT THE DEFENSE OF MARRIAGE
ACT -- A LOT OF PEOPLE FORGET
THAT.
THIS WAS AFTER THE '94
SHELLACKING THE DEMOCRATS HAD IN
THAT MIDTERM ELECTION CYCLE.
CLINTON IS LIKE, WELL, I HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOW.
THAT MADE SENSE.
EVEN DURING HIS LIFE'S CAMPAIGN,
HE REPORTEDLY CONFRONTED HER
STAFF ABOUT THEIR SEEMING
DISINTEREST IN WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS, AND HE REPORTEDLY
URGED THEM TO REACH OUT TO THOSE
VOTERS WHO WERE FEELING IGNORED.
HIS ADVICE WAS DISMISSED.
LED BY ROBBIE MOO, HILLARY'S
CAMPAIGN DECIDED TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON TARGETING YOUNG, LATINO, AND
BLACK VOTERS IN THEIR EFFORT
TO WIN THE PRESIDENCY.
THAT WORKED OUT WELL.
LIKE BILL CLINTON'S FAILURE TO
READ THE SIGNS OF THE TIMES, AND
APPRECIATE THE LESSONS OF THE
PAST, DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RESPECT THE
VOTERS THAT TRUMP HAS BROUGHT
INTO THE FOLD.
SHOULD THIS CONTINUE, CLINTON
AND JAMES PATTERSON MAY WANT TO
RECONSIDER, LIKE, A NEW TITLE,
MAY BE, FOR THEIR BOOK WHEN IT
PREMIERES IN PAPERBACK?